سؤال صاحب السعاده اود ان اطرح السؤال
الاول بالنسبه الى ما يسمى باليوم الذي
يلي هذه الحرب الفظيعه وشكل الحكم في قطاع
غزه اولا السؤال الاول هو هل تتخيلون ان
حركه حماس سوف تؤدي دورا في حكم قطاع غزه
و في دوله فلسطينيه مستقبليه اسرائيل
تعارض ذلك بشده ما موقف قطر موقفنا هو
ان الدوله الفلسطينيه يجب ان تكون بين
ايدي الفلسطينيين لكي يقرروا طريقه الحكم
بالنسبه الينا قطاع غزه لا يمكن التعامل
معه بشكل منفصل عن الضفه الغربيه يجب ان
يكون هناك حكومه واحده تعنى بقطاع غزه
وبضه الغربيه في ان معا والسلطه
الفلسطينيه بغض النظر عن الاصلاحات طبعا
هذا امر يعود
الى القرار الفلسطيني والمجموعات
الفلسطينيه هي التي تقرر لا قطر ولا
اسرائيل ولا اي طرف اخر يمكنه ان يملي على
الفلسطينيين امرا ما او ما نراه نحن
مناسبا لهم